we welcome in the commissioner of the
NBA Adam Silver good to have you with us
thank you Matt I was thinking about this
this is your 10th NBA Finals as
commissioner wow coming up by quickly
yeah it's amazing I am curious what have
you learned about this job
in nearly a decade doing it well you
know it's actually my 30th here I think
when you include the number of years
I've been at the league so I had the
opportunity to work with the three Hall
of Famers under David Stern for all
those years so what I've learned is how
Global this game is becoming look now
we're over a quarter of the players uh
you know we're now born outside the
United States you know last MB five MVPs
have been you know international players
and also just how much this game has
grown globally number two sport in the
world after soccer and number one
participation sport among kids in the
United States so I think there's so much
opportunity ahead of us that and also
just lastly focusing on all these new
technologies so many people now one
thing that certainly wasn't happening
even when I became Commissioners so many
people were watching games on their
phones you know and that opportunity
just make it that much more accessible
to fans everywhere we've got a first
time NBA finalist here and of course the
Miami Heat a mid-sized market and as you
know there's a lot of analysis about
what the market sizes and the teams
involved means to the NBA from your
perspective from a business perspective
how much does the match-up matter the
match-up matters not because of the
market size but because of the
excitement around the game and I think
where we're getting to by definition the
teams that are in the finals are the
teams that people want to watch because
they're the ones who fought through a
long regular season through the playoffs
to be here and I think even talking to
players they recognize that it used to
be very different I mean these guys know
that a market could determine what the
economics were what your opportunities
are that's not the case anymore that
it's a global game games are all
available available digitally everywhere
and if the the success comes from the
success on the floor and so here you
have really two mid-sized markets in
Miami and Denver and and to me that's a
non-factor it's just they're the teams
that deserve to be here because they won
on the court and that's why they're in
the finals the other day you touched on
the John Moran situation and you said
you didn't want to take away from the
NBA Finals how tough was it for you to
make that decision based on this new
information that you have
it wasn't that difficult and and as I
said also that in talking The Players
Association they agreed I mean they they
don't know what we're planning to do yet
In fairness to them they're not signing
on to whatever the discipline might be
you know I don't know what their point
of view is going to be but I think they
agreed on behalf of these teams on
behalf of these players that shouldn't
be the focus of attention going into the
finals
Forest commissioner you go
you go to the playoffs and you think
that this would would have been an
unexpected NBA Finals but throughout the
playoffs you've had seven series that
were won by the lower seed including
three by the Miami Heat right so could
you speak to the state of competition
right now in the NBA yeah you know it's
interesting Grant this season just
measured by by wins and losses it was
actually the most competitive season in
the entire history of the NBA and you
had partly because of the addition of
the playing tournament you had 26 teams
with 10 days left in the season that
were still competing for a playoff spot
and so what we saw here is that you know
of course the heat we're a playing team
and on the other hand you have the first
seed you know in the Western Conference
two teams that fought hard all
throughout the regular season you know
coach SPO said the other day you know
about embracing the grind of the regular
season they both thought fought through
injuries struggled at times through the
regular season but I think it it speaks
volumes about this level of competition
I think you talk to players around the
league and you guys know this there are
no nights off I mean maybe once upon a
time and I'm looking at the hall of
famers to say whether that was ever the
case that there were nights off in this
league but now you know every team is
loaded there's so much competition out
there in the league that you know you
got to bring your best all the time
are you concerned about the great
turnover rate of the coaches in the
league now because man guys who have won
championships are like getting powered
left and right after a couple years now
well I mean I'm always concerned about
anybody losing their job I mean they're
they're friends of all of ours I'm
incredibly empathetic to anybody a
terrible thing to get fired uh uh from
your job having said that three of those
head coaches have already been rehired
at other team and to this one you when
you look at it statistically it's not
all that Aboriginal to where we've been
historically I mean it may be to your
point teams are quicker to pull the
trigger than they used to be and it was
a different set of coaches that were
necessarily getting fired I think what
it speaks to is how many teams think
they have a legitimate shot to compete
and they think by making that change
that may put them you know over the you
know make that make help them turn the
corner to compete but um the good news
is I think the great coaches if they
leave one team they seem to get rehired
at another yeah but and but that was
going to be my follow-up question and do
you like seeing retreads that quickly
would you like to see some young blood
honestly both I mean and I think it's
interesting that those same coaches that
won Championship so recently got let go
from a team another team then picks them
up so obviously they didn't go from
being a great coach to a bad coach
overnight they recognized the talent
there on the other hand to your point
you want new coaches to be able to break
through the system and so you also see
for example in Boston you see now you
know in Milwaukee you know another new
coach you know who's who's come up
through the rank so you want to see both
I mean but most importantly to your
earlier question I mean I feel for guys
losing their jobs we know it's not I'm
into the outside world there's a lot of
glamor and high pay and stuff that comes
with them but there's enormous
dislocation to their families to them
it's it's terrible to lose your job we
all know that Adam it was recently
discovered on social media that one of
your referees had a burner account could
you explain to the fans why that would
be a problem if it is a problem at all
you know I'm only I'm going to hold off
on that just because we what we said was
he wasn't you know Eric Louis he wasn't
going to work the finals you know
because we were reviewing the situation
and we're going to continue to review it
yeah thank you what about the collective
bargaining agreement in principle that
has been reported other than the fact
that there won't be an interruption in
games in the near future what about that
agreement pleases you most well the most
thing that pleases me is the the best
part of it means we're going to have
Labor peace through 2030 and this is yet
another collective bargaining cycle
where we came together with the players
and the Players Association led by
Tamika tremelio and we said let's not go
right up to the line where we risk
having a work stop which even a summer
work stop let's sit down let's really
focus on it I think you know CJ McComb
is president of the Players Association
picked up right after Chris Paul and
really focused on it and we said we got
to compromise
um you know I think the ownership
compromise the players compromise and
said there's nothing more important than
make sure we have Labor stability and
not just on behalf of the players but I
mean you guys know through whether it's
our broadcasting Partners the arena
Partners there's literally tens of
thousands of jobs that are dependent on
this league and big you know in a
difficult economy people came together
and said let's make sure we keep things
going specifically in terms of the
agreement I think I'm pleased we're
adding this in-season tournament I'm
excited about that we added some issues
to address you know so-called load
management you know incentivize guys to
stay on the floor in the regular season
we know that's an issue you guys talk
about it a lot on air I think we look
for other opportunities to continue to
build the league and create more
competition that's what we did through
by making some adjustments in the salary
cap I want that to like I don't
understand the mid-season tournament can
you clarify that to us yeah I think the
notion there is taking a page from
international soccer where they have
other things to compete for not just in
our case the Larry O'Brien trophy so
we're actually taking for the most part
a series of games regular season games
and we're and we're designating those as
tournament games kind of like what they
do in European soccer and so those those
games will count both for the regular
season and for this in season tournament
and then the the four teams that are
still standing will come together and
we'll go to a neutral site we haven't
designated that site yet and then
they'll play for a separate you know in
essence a separate Trophy and it'll be a
new tradition it'll probably take a
little bit while to get it going but you
know I think what you guys know in this
league it's a long season to play for
one championship at the end and it's not
going to replace the Larry O'Brien
trophy but it's our hope that just like
in college there's a lot of you know
there's a Thanksgiving tournament or a
holiday tournament and guys who play in
those tournaments they care about
winning it's not a replacement for the
NCAA tournament but it's to give a
little bit something more special a
little bit more incentive around those
games so these are the weaker teams or
the better teams it's every team is
competing every team is competing well
okay so
we already got the load management issue
okay
why would our risk if I'm one of the
team to trying to win the Laro Brian
trophy
why would I what's in it for me to play
in that tournament we always having a
hard time getting these guys it's
absolutely fair question we've talked to
players a lot about first of all all of
the games except for the well the games
also count towards the regular season so
you have the same incentive to care
about your record and there's prize
money and it's significant so there's a
financial incentive too to compete okay
so
you talked earlier I mean Nicola jokic
obviously from Serbia Joel B won the MVP
this year five of the times in the MVP
uh race this year where International
Players you touched on it earlier the
the growth of the game but just if you
could elaborate in more detail of the
benefits of the international growth
here in this league well a couple of
things first of all just in terms of the
talent if you look now as I said you
know we're a quarter of our players
going quickly to a third born outside
United States and you know whether it's
Nicola or Giannis you know or or Joelle
I mean these are difference makers you
know it's again three Hall of Famers
here there's only so many of those
players that exist on the planet who can
come in and really make the difference
between being a good team and a truly
great team so one it's just and that's
who fans want to see the very best
players out there and then there's now
where media is going the streaming
services for example that are interested
in MBA rights are Global and so whether
it's in Europe or in Africa where these
players are coming from they want
subscribers and the fact is that if you
are Giana and your Greek you know it
only takes one player to turn that
country on or Nikola from Serbia that
you know even when our games are on at
two o'clock in the morning people are
staying up you know and setting their
alarm clocks because they want to see
their countrymen compete so if you
really want to be a global Sport and
deliver a global audience you want to
have a global group of players and so
that's where it really makes a
difference that leads me to my last
question for you and it has to do with
media rights because that's one of the
things on your plate moving forward the
next couple of years there are two years
left on the current meteor rights
agreement you can begin negotiations I
believe next spring if I'm not mistaken
I know you don't know the particulars of
how that's going to play out but for
fans out there for consumers of the NBA
what is your expectation in terms of the
biggest change that they will see after
that agreement is struck I think most
importantly first of all like your
parent companies now Warner Brothers
Discovery like we love our relationship
it's our longest standing media
relationship you guys are all part of
you know that Network we want to make
sure we continue with our great Partners
same thing for Disney which is ESPN and
ABC but on top of that I mean I think a
good example is inside the NBA on TNT
it's the greatest sports show on
television Emmy award-winning greatest
talent but increasingly there's limited
numbers of people who can see it because
not everybody gets TNT anymore not
everybody subscribes to cable so if it
were up to me I would want to be on
every possible platform so if somebody
isn't
subscribing to basic cable and getting
TNT and want to just watch it on their
phone and you can just sign up and watch
Inside the NBA on your phone and that
that to me is where our business is
going like partnering with these great
media companies but making games more
accessible and increasingly I'm sure
it's the same for all of us you know
we're watching programming on your
phones on your iPads I mean people are
still going to pay for great programming
but right now you can't even get a lot
of our games because they're locked up
as part of a Cable Bundle so that's what
changes we're going to see and I think
it's going to really benefit live sports
because you don't have to be home you
don't have to have a particular package
if you want to watch a game it's a click
away you know you'll just like music or
whatever else you'll pay a fair price
for it but it's going to make accessible
including not just the games but great
shows like inside the NBA also uh Adam
last question they want us to go but I
need this question answered with with
everything going so well do you see in
the near future more expansion teams
like you hear Seattle you hear Las Vegas
is that a possibility it is a
possibility and I think what we've said
in the last few years number one we
wanted to get our collective bargaining
agreement done so we've done that now
and the other thing we wanted to
understand what our new meteorites
packages are and you know as Matt said
those negotiations will begin you know
in Earnest probably in this next spring
once that's done we'll turn to expansion
you know we don't have anything specific
in mind right now but I think it makes
sense over time you know if you're
success if you're a successful
organization to continue to grow there's
no doubt there's a lot of great cities
we're interested in having the MBA so
just a few things on your to-do list
Stu you want to be a commissioner of the
NBA you got to know all that stuff thank
you guys good to have you with us as
always thank you man enjoy the finals
the commissioner of the NBA presiding
over his tennis
again four or five six seven
my jurisdiction does not extend to
Shaquille O'Neal